the eight news now i-team exposed
security concerns at a local courthouse
in fact this is a story that you saw
last night here at 11 o'clock on eight
news now and now they're looking deeper
into what the law says about carrying
guns in public buildings including where
judges are presiding the i-team's david
charns here live in studio now david
what did you find state law says you can
bring a concealed firearm into most
public buildings here in nevada like the
courthouse in nye county we showed you
right here last night the judges there
are worried about safety after the
commissioners in nye county voted to
remove the weapons ban in the building
you see there that they work in the
county owns the building the
commissioners say they control the
hallways the courts are just part of the
building and there is no security at the
front door state law says it is not
illegal for public employees to carry
concealed firearms at work what makes it
illegal if
is if there is a sign like this one or
some sort of security like a metal
detector at the door
just a sign prevents guns coming into
public buildings
but you know when you think about it the
only thing that protects the judges and
the public and our employees here at the
courthouse
is a piece of paper i
think that probably the greatest threat
or risk
for an incident is in the hallways or in
the parking lot
now the county voted to take those signs
down allowing concealed firearms in the
hallways to the judge's courtrooms and
offices again this just involves
concealed firearms the law
isn't just a free-for-all now this law
has been on the books for a while since
1995 previous lawmakers have implied by
keeping it in place employees who have
concealed firearms act as a deterrent to
people who may want to cause some harm
certainly keep you posted on any
developments from this story i'm david
charns live local now